NYPD investigated it they thought it was
enough and they wrote up a report to say
this person should be arrested and grace
jaari even turned herself in so the NYPD
thought it was a crime but Alvin Bragg
didn't and I think that's where it gets
a little contentious for the defense so
many of you have noticed the kind of
controversy and contradiction of
Jonathan Majors being fired by Marvel
Studios which is Disney because of
course Disney owns Marvel Studios but
then then immediately after Disney fires
him he does his first interview since he
was arrested and consequently found
guilty of harassing his ex-girlfriend
and who gets the exclusive interview
Disney It's a Good Morning America
interview which is owned by ABC News
which is owned Again by Disney and now
there's a new piece on Jonathan major
that came out last night it's an impact
piece done by ABC News again owned by
Disney and is streaming right now on
Hulu owned by Disney a lot of people
have been pointing this out and I
believe that at this point and this is
strictly my own opinion not based off of
anything besides what everybody else has
seen but I believe what is happening
here is a couple of things but one I
believe Disney really is trying to kind
of get a feel for how the public feels
about this situation and I've heard from
a lot of you I've covered this for a
pretty long time now since he was
arrested but in the comments down below
specifically please tell if you think
Jonathan major despite being found
guilty of two unintentional harassment
charges meaning that he did indeed
harass and hurt Grace Jabari but the
jury deemed that he didn't mean to it
was accidental so given what the jury
has currently found we going to ignore
the fact that he's going to appeal based
off of how everything is right now
please let me know in the comments if
you think Jonathan major should be
rehired by Disney Marvel as king the
Conqueror in the MCU based off being
found guilty of those two harassment
charges Now ABC has confirmed that
Jonathan major said he is going to be
appealing the verdict and in this new
piece done by ABC it's actually a piece
that kind of really does favor Jonathan
Majors they are trying to tell his side
of the story they're trying to tell the
story of what a lot of people didn't see
behind the scenes that happened that the
court kind of chose to ignore or the
police chose to ignore and in this new
piece that they've done they bring in
Brian buckmire who is an a BC News legal
contributor and he brings up some good
points again in favor of Jonathan major
and really this new piece by ABC News
really does make it seem like Jonathan
major is the victim in this situation
even though he was found guilty it seems
like he was wrongfully found guilty
that's sort of the vibe that you get
from this piece and we'll play clips of
course and break it down we'll start
with this first one that has ABC News
and Jonathan major saying grace Jabari
said this but this is what actually
happened Jonathan major was actually
injured he went to the police and the
police thought that it was enough to
erase Grace jbari but the da did not and
he dismissed it in the criminal
complaint she alleged major struck her
in the face with an open hand causing
substantial pain and a laceration behind
her ear then Majors grabbed her hand
causing swelling bruising and
substantial pain to her finger and that
he put his hand on her neck causing
bruising but Majors claims ja Ari
attacked him in a jealous rage ripping
his coat scratching his face and his arm
photos he took in Cesar of his injuries
were shared with impact yet were deemed
inadmissible in court and what's
interesting about this is that Majors
did go to the police about what happened
he actually went to the police about
Grace Jabari assaulting him and the NYPD
actually issued a warrant for the arrest
of Grace Jabari and she turned herself
in however the da dismissed this and
people found this very interesting at
the time and ABC News brought on Brian
buckmire to talk about this situation
part about this cross complaint is that
the NYPD investigated it they thought it
was enough and they wrote up a report to
say this person should be arrested and
Grace Jabari even turned herself in so
the NYPD thought it was a crime but
Alvin Bragg didn't and I think that's
where it gets a little contentious for
the defense now this is one of the
reasons that Jonathan Majors is going to
appeal and they feel like there just
wasn't enough evidence to support the
case that Jonathan major harmed and
caused all of these injuries to Grace
Jabari Jonathan major remains adamant
that he never touched her and he only
tried to get his phone back and then she
started to harass him and he tried to
get away she followed he tried to put
her back in the car and then ran away
after and Brian buckmire actually
mentioned a law before when Jonathan
major was found guilty he said this
right after that could be a pretty big
changer for Jonathan major if he appeals
and he said he was actually shocked that
it wasn't brought up before here's what
Brian buckmeier had to say about it this
is the difficult part for me and this is
where I was getting trouble at home when
I try to break this down to my wife um
what I didn't like about this defense is
they didn't focus on what is called
penala 3525 it's the ability to use
Force to stop a Larsen or theft or
criminal mischief the damage of your
property and I always go back to this
analogy that I've said multiple times in
ABC if and I'll use Kira use an example
if Kira's walking down the street and
someone takes her purse the law says
you're allowed to use Force to take your
property back the law doesn't say well
your girlfriend's allowed to take your
cell phone because she's allowed to
check for infidelity the law doesn't say
well my wife's allowed uh to or I'm
allowed to take my wife's property
because I need to check it for this or
that no to me this broke down to Grace
Jabari stealing property and Jonathan
majers using Force now the question is
is it appropriate Force to take back his
property but that seemed to be an
argument that was missed completely in
this trial I'm not sure quite why so
this will most likely be brought up in
court when Jonathan major appeals so now
kind of the big question going around is
will Disney take back Jonathan major if
he is found not guilty after he appeals
or even if the verdict stays the same
and he is still found guilty we'll talk
about this in just a bit but first big
thank you to fume for sponsoring this
video fume is a GameChanger for a lot of
people in turning bad habits into good
habits a lot of people struggle with
these bad habits but fume looks at these
in a different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things in the bad Habit in it
instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to try
fum.fi
to save an additional 10% off your order
today so as I mentioned I do kind of
feel like this is Disney trying to get a
feel for how everybody is feeling about
Jonathan Majors because if you're Disney
if you're Marvel Studios you don't want
to have to recast Jonathan major he's
already appeared several times in the
MCU they've made it clear that he is the
big bad of the entire Saga and they
showed us the Council of Kings they
showed us thousands of KS all being
played by Jonathan major there's his
face on all of those different variants
if if you're Marvel you don't want to
have to recast him especially if you
have known him for a very long time and
you think he is a good person and let's
remember Marvel Studios and Disney fired
James gun before and then after a little
bit brought him back James gun issued an
apology and everything was fine and
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 was the
most successful Marvel Studios film in a
very long time so clearly they have seen
that people surrounded in controversy
doesn't necessarily mean the failure of
movie or franchise that they're involved
in and this new piece on Jonathan Majors
makes sure to put some very specific
things inside of it like the fact that
Jonathan major still believes that it
was racism behind Grace Jabari not
getting arrested and the evidence of him
being hurt not being allowed to be used
in court even though the da was a black
man himself as they said there are those
who would say look you know the da Alvin
brag is a black man how can you say that
that this is race involved oh Alvin brag
is a black man I'm a black man um he's a
politician you
know we are not limited to our race the
system you know the country um there are
elements of it that are
just bad the District Attorney's Office
declined to comment on major's interview
saying we do our speaking in court where
a Manhattan jury convicted Mr major and
then they they make sure to state that
the charges that he was facing were
downgraded and he was only charged with
two of the four that were being held
against him and they made sure to
explain that the charges that were being
held against him now are him hurting her
by accident listen here not guilty of
the assault in the third degree
intentionally suggests that the jury
says he didn't mean to hurt her but they
didn't say that he was guilty of
Reckless assault meaning that he
basically conducted himself in a way
where he should have known better and
unintentionally injured someone else so
they're really focusing on the fact that
look Jonathan Maes was found guilty of
harassment and causing these injuries on
Grace Jabari but it was not intentional
he did not seek out to hurt her he was
trying to get his phone back and they
happened he was trying to get away from
her and these injuries happened by
accident he did not mean to do this so
the big question now is if this really
was an accident if he did not truly
harass and abuse her is that worth his
his entire career being destroyed is an
accident something that didn't mean to
happen something that he did not plan on
happening that just happened because of
recklessness which is what the jury said
is that worth him being completely
canceled in Hollywood and never working
in Hollywood again being fired as king
the Conqueror and never being hired
again or was he a human that made a
mistake and should be given a second
chance which is what they said in the
first interview release they asked him
if he deserves a second chance and he
said yes I think everybody did does and
he hopes that people would agree so I
think this is a good new piece done by
ABC News because it definitely tells
more of the story of Jonathan Major's
side and this definitely does position
Disney in a better spot for if they did
want to rehire him especially if he is
found not guilty when he appeals I think
at that point it would be a lot easier
now that they've done all of this and
shared his side of the story it would be
a lot easier now if he's found not
guilty to rehire him because they simply
say well we're not going to fire him if
he's not guilty of something that's one
of the big questions but the other big
question is could they possibly rehire
him if they see that the public is okay
with that and they want that to happen
and it was still just kind of an
accident so could they rehire him as
king the Conqueror if he perhaps issues
an apology these are the big questions
that we are waiting for also in the
beginning of February he will find out
his sentence it's believed that he won't
do any jail time at all possibly just
community service but of course we won't
find out until we find out in the
meantime let me know your thoughts on
this new story of Jonathan Majors by ABC
News in the comments down below please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the channel to stay up to
date on MCU news also if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for chance to
win an Xbox series X PlayStation 5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof